Samuel leads here we're out in  stoke-on-trent Hanley Shopping Center  and it's absolutely fantastic and some  great restaurants we've got Nando's  taquitos Frankie and Benny's Cineworld  beautiful views I'm out with sue and  Jonathan we've just bought a house and  what did you think of your house at you  see it for the first time ever there is  please they're very pleased kick and  your house very cheap is in good  condition good condition and yet we used  to pleasantly surprised  I'll show us yeah how about you sir yes  us and how much rent are you hoping to  achieve four thousand finders 1,400 what  a fantastic property so if you are  looking to invest in property give us a  shout get yourself on the waiting list